all right no doubt no patreon stuff
let's get into the topic solve you are
up I believe games come what's going on
stuff it was happening yeah we got
Gamescom coming up on August 23rd uh you
know we have all Opening Night Live
coming up as well so you know Kelly
always has some surprises for us and we
also know that going into Gamescom that
there will be a Starfield theater
presentation in addition to a Forza
theater presentation yes
um in addition to maybe some of that
stuff being on the show floor right
Nintendo's gonna be there as well and
with certain leaks you never know maybe
maybe some information at the very least
it seems like maybe some conversations
isn't going to be had with other uh
Publishers and third-party Partners to
get their hands on uh some of that uh
hardware and that's it we know
PlayStation is not going to be there so
I just want to see where you guys are at
in terms of gamecom has not
traditionally been the place for the uh
you know secondary mic drop moments
right we know so but you never know and
with certain things leaking out maybe
some companies want to get out in front
of some messaging
um one thing that I saw that seriously
interested me and it came out a little
bit earlier I think it came out in July
was that the official Gamescom app
accidentally oh what they do showed
something for half-life
from valve interesting so hmm
PlayStation VR too yeah you would think
it well no PlayStation presence maybe
not but you know maybe maybe Gabe
learned how to count to three I don't
know I doubt it
but we'll see that that's very
interesting to me right um because
Half-Life is something that just hasn't
since Alex we haven't seen anything they
haven't indicated they would ever plan
to go back and and kind of finish the
the trilogy or whatever the case may be
so that's interesting to me so I want to
know what you guys think about what
might be coming down the pipeline for
Gamescom cool addict what we thinking
man what's your predictions a lot of
presents they put out a big uh blog post
about a booth and all this stuff where
you at
I think it's about fan you know
attendance uh they want to make sure
people there that go there for the Xbox
brand have stuff to play you know I saw
a lot of people upset that you know
Starfield wasn't there I feel like you
could be disappointed but to like like
try to say something's wrong with the
game just because they're not at an
event that's four days before the game
comes out I think that's that's a little
bit of a reach I I don't expect too much
of this I expect maybe but is it a
reach-around wow
that gives off the beat now that's you
want that one or you want to be the
other one well it's extra is that hey
hey hey
and now there's five
um you know I think it's just one of
those things where it's like look they
are going to
let you play these games you know we we
ain't really had too much Hands-On on
something like stalker yeah
what I find interesting is the from
software games going to be there on
their stage what's that about you what
are we thinking we think oh they got the
marketing
I might think you own a shot maybe if
they don't maybe the reason that
it's on their their floors because
PlayStation's not theirs so I mean I
mean if there's not another stage to go
on but to me it's like if if PlayStation
had the marketing there's no way they
would be okay with their game being on
their show I would agree that's right so
I think they got the marketing for that
it's interesting
we should say you know what comes with
the Starfield thing look if you're
frustrated that it's not going to be
there I get it but no demo the game
comes out four days later so at that
point what's the point but they do have
like a theater experience going on where
they show you stuff and you know I get
it but I understand why people are are
disappointed it's not there because
we've seen more gameplay but I just
don't understand how people are trying
to act like this is like bad news for
the game into the world and shout out to
Delilah she said why are people upset
the starfield's not there because
Spider-Man's not there either
I see what we do yeah there's a lot of a
lot of concern uh addicts everything
that's what they say they like concerns
they like no damage you know no
marketing the marketing is is not
concerning to me it's disappointing
because I feel like the game is good
it's just I don't understand why
Microsoft isn't marketing the game to
the to the degree that they should I
mean they have a I haven't seen one
commercial for Starfield now obviously
huh I said I've seen tons of them you've
seen commercials
it's cartoons like oh you talk about the
anime thing okay I feel you I feel you
on that but I don't I I don't feel like
that
is Justified marketing for a brand new
IP made by the developers that has made
multiple Game of the Year contenders or
game of the years it that that's what my
only thing it's like you know normally
I'm against traditional marketing but
for this particular title maybe you
should do a little bit of that you know
I want to see that chick from the from
the posters everywhere on billboards
everywhere now obviously when it comes
like YouTube advertising promoting I'm a
I'm a member of um
of YouTube premium so they might be
rolling you to uh you know
people in the chat if you've seen a star
filled
a Starfield commercial on YouTube tell
me because I'm very curious on that
because I have premium I don't see that
why you don't have premium I have broken
I have isn't this isn't this kind of
like par for the course for them though
like I kind of feel like you know with
Fallout 4 they announced it you know at
E3 or whatever and then they launched it
later that year and I don't even know
what they marketed a lot in between the
announcement and when it came out so I
don't mean Bethesda generally Skyrim a
lot but maybe bgs maybe BTS goes proper
just like yeah it was super close yeah
Skyrim was different Skyrim was was
further sort of out
um I don't know maybe that's kind of par
for the course for them and they don't
want to spoil anything
um I get it but at the same time you
would think that press starts needs to
start having this game already I would
agree I would agree I agree so it's got
to be out there right soon if I'm
talking about if not already next week
when you think about it or have a good
two to three weeks with the game before
and that that might not realistically
enough apparently Baldur's Gate 3 went
out like three or four days before the
game yeah like they didn't get it
anything yeah but we also I'm sorry okay
my bad kid what'd you say no I said that
was a stadia game
in Early Access for a long time and not
that that game didn't like just
transform after it hit 1.0 like it was
the same game so one thing we all forget
in though it looks like Starfield will
be there since attendees will be able to
check out exclusive theater
presentations of it of itself so they
got to show it in some capacity just no
demo just no demoing yeah I'm okay with
that like I guess people because I'm not
going to Gamescom so that might be
disappointing on that front but I
looking at it doesn't feel like that is
something that's bad like oh you know
Starfield is in at Gamescom everyone
pack it up pack up the trucks we're not
we're not playing it game comes out four
days after games called so at that point
you might might as well just wait four
days after game's gone shout out to
boxing Burger he said he's got a seat
booked in the Starfield and Forza
theater present test right Germany in
the building that's nice boxing but yeah
you got to let us know man y'all let us
know how concerned you are about that
demo that lack of demo now that's dope
you're gonna be up in the middle of the
salute so uh Lord King your thoughts on
this whole thing about the uh Gamescom
your little predictions which they gonna
do and then uh what's the office talk
about about Starfield well um the movie
thing as far as showing you know
Starfield and Forza
um that's good I don't think uh
releasing Starfield
as a playable demo they will have to
craft the demo yep uh get that demo uh
get that demo ready put that demo uh
through its Paces all this other stuff
you have to bug test the demo do all
this stuff just for Gamescom all right
so you get the game out to Gamescom and
then is it representative of the whole
game you know um RPG is very hard to do
in in that short period of Time how long
would them will be what would the lines
look like yeah
I think it made more headache than it uh
solved um any uh you know questions it's
a hard game to demo you would think yeah
that's a hard game to demo the only
thing I would like really think and I
don't even know if it would be enough to
satisfy people is like have a couple you
know chaos where you could jump on and
and just play around with the
customization of your character uh but
if you only offered people well these
are the options yeah they're gonna be
bad oh they hiding what can I play why
can't I play the game they not
comfortable showing right and then and
then the opposite you don't want to do
making a character you don't want to do
a red fall either and be like yeah it's
a vertical slice and it's very polished
just came off redfall too yeah so I just
want to say
um majority of this is the mustard heart
Xbox dude
you have the mustard heart Xbox dudes
that's out here like a mustard I need to
I need to see it first before I I buy it
because my heart is
people not to be cautious they could be
as cautious as they want I Got Game Pass
I don't care
um you can have game pass too
um it's not exclusive to me so at the
same time the PlayStation dudes no
PlayStation ain't gonna be there so of
course they're gonna throw a battery in
the back of the mustard heart dude they
smack the battery in the back of the
mustard dude and say run go spread the
word that something's wrong with
Starfield and then you know the monster
heart dudes out in the street I think
something's wrong with Starfield they're
not showing it I think something's wrong
with Sony they're not there
think about that you can make that
argument definitely it's like and you
know what's funny Spider-Man would be an
easier game to have a demo for yeah it
would be an easier game lost Jim has not
been seen like Jim has turned into Waldo
I'm looking for Jim wherever we can find
Jim at we saw a site in the gym
someplace in Nebraska it was kind of
crazy
but listen
I I see what they're gonna do I don't
think anything great comes out of
Gamescom maybe some minor stuff nothing
crazy Gamescom has never been oh this is
where we're gonna release new stuff
usually what they do is whatever they
did for E3 with all the shows that they
had with the Bethesda shows they uh
streamline it and and get a nice little
package together and put it up for
Gamescom and it looks like a better
presentable package whatever they did
wrong
at E3 and uh the shows after E3 they
kind of clean it up for Gamescom gamecom
has a better presentation and I expect
that I expect Microsoft you know the
strut Day stuff knowing that in four
days after that Starfield will launch
and I believe that they know they have a
winner that's why they're going to give
you the the movie theater thing and the
forza I'm I'm more concerned
you know why isn't that playable why
isn't that there those little questions
that I have right so if they're going to
give you a trailer of Forza
um are you going to expound or are they
leaving it to turn 10 with the forza
events and allow them to present it on
their platform because you know Falls is
a huge thing to have a large community
so maybe they're allowing them to
present it to their audience that way
and then after that piggyback off of
that but I'm a little bit concerned with
Forza I've heard great things from
everybody everybody that's in the
background that I know of told me that
this is it this is the one this is the
thing and I'm like all right cool but
can I see it and they're like we send
out some pictures but
um other than that I I just think
Microsoft is playing it safe they're
going to hold their cards close to
breast because Sony's not gonna be there
anyway don't need to flex for no reason
nothing I mean look this is a big deal
um for them to actually say you know
we're gonna have a big presence at
Gamescom is pretty huge you know to see
them let's be honest like we go to pax's
either to see Xbox have a booth again is
a big deal you know what I mean and then
we talk about all these uh other times
that we're not even talking about the
150 other titles we're talking also like
the uh stalker is going to actually be
there playable that's a good sign
because that that studio we know what's
going on in real life right with the
with the war and stuff like that and all
the terrible stuff that they had to
endure so to have them there to me that
seems like oh maybe they they'd be ready
hopefully at the top of 2024 or
something like that potentially that'll
be interesting um with the demo thing I
hear y'all I'm not gonna say that I
don't want demos but it's like King said
the reality is that cuts development
time you got to make a whole vertical
slice to sit there and then bug test a
half for a demo and for Starfield it
makes it doesn't even make sense exactly
small Philly makes absolutely no sense
like you're literally four days after
the show and it's gonna be in somebody
house like it literally makes your game
I prefer those people that would make
that
six months ago
work on the game yeah right and let's
let's be real right based on track
record and history and the complexity of
that game it kind of makes we would like
you to continue to work all the way
through you know what I'm saying right
so Forza should be there in some way
shape or form and some kind of playable
I get it I'm all about demos I'm never
gonna say no I just think like there's
two things I think that is changing you
know the the demo from development
cycles and then I also think the
marketing is changing I know you know
the homie kissing was in the cross eye
right now but like this is what I think
no idea
I already know I haven't paid attention
to the latest but I'll just go about
what I what I saw last week you know I
understand this concern listen I want
Starfield to be on of course poster
boards trains buses all I get it but we
also got to look at what's effective and
they may have the metrics look at what
we're about to talk about Baldur's Gate
right yeah you know marketing football
this game do you see what it's doing it
just dropped and it's the viral the
reality of of people just say yo you
know it's good Metacritic that what I
what I realized is if they may be
looking at it the corporate saying look
all these millions we're gonna pour into
this marketing and we could literally
have the community of social media do
this and have the same effect if not
better than wasting all this money doing
this also I think the get the rules have
changed a little bit now credit this
only they're still doing things their
way you know I'm saying for the most
part you know what I'm saying especially
with Spider-Man but like I just think I
think slowly the industry is changing in
that it's almost like you know what
reminds me of King it reminds me of e3
how people were like yo do we really
need to be there right and spend all
this money for the booth all this money
thing or we could do our little direct
version show that self-contained that we
control the message
it's cutting money yes from from
trimming the fat right you don't want to
access spend uh it's not traditional no
more we're no longer in a traditional
state know everything has changed
literally since covert so the the ways
that you market now is completely
different I've seen marketing for
Starfield so I'm not going to say like I
didn't see marketing for Starfield I see
it when I go past bus stops I see like
the Billboards for it so um I'm not
gonna say I don't see that I saw the
commercials I mean um I have regular
YouTube so I guess I get a chance to see
the the commercials but I thought it was
dope the commercial and um I talked to
Colt about it and I was and he was
joking he said you know that better not
be the animation I'm like nah I don't
think so but it was it was just a nice
little little type of story whatever I
don't know something whatever's minor
that they can do to try to go viral yeah
holes to oh we gotta buy out all of them
downtown bro put up bull boards that's a
lot of money that doesn't make any sense
anymore people don't even interact that
way not getting it like I said again not
saying and I don't want it you know I'm
just saying I gotta look at practicality
and if they got the metrics to say yo we
spent all this money on buses for
Hogwarts and all this stuff and this
really didn't equate to what we thought
you know for certain games it may not
gonna be effective right was You Gonna
Take It Well by plenty of people in the
marketing saying that influencer
streaming and podcast marketing is ex
way more effective than shotgun
marketing you know put the only thing I
would push back a little bit yeah go
ahead is I like the way PlayStation
markets like on the Subways and stuff oh
that's why I love that oh I love that
how many people
I I'm not in New York but I'm assuming
Millions
when they had a horizon and on God of
War in Grand Central Station sick yeah I
was sick because Grand Central really
really is like a hub right so
everybody's going different directions
want to hit Grand Central everywhere you
go every little tunnel hallway had it
was Sony down like it was it was crazy
it was really good yeah I mean now the
question is again I don't know the
numbers I'm not trying to be slanderous
but like if we look at Horizon you know
here we go did it do the 10 million
right did it do you know this is what
Jim Ryan I'm just talking about he wants
these things to be better so let's just
say I'm just throwing up a number please
PlayStation do not come at me I don't
know what the [__] I'm saying
but let's just say Horizon end up doing
alone you know three four to five is
that enough for them to justify a
million or whatever it is on the
marketing budget that you spent to put
all these trainings whereas Baldur's
Gate spent nothing let's just say you
know
than even maybe a Super Bowl commercial
like like game like that no okay
me personally it's a lot of money bro no
I'm like stop that like I would rather
go a lot of money too well yeah but I
would rather go get random streamers and
let them play the game and save a
boatload of cash uh it's it's we Market
different yeah and and okay so let's say
talk about the digital kids right we're
talking to the digital kids because
we're not really talking to the adults
the adults we we pretty much know what
we're gonna buy the digital kids that
you're trying to catch their eye
on a train station looking at Spider-Man
on a train actually I got a perfect
example for you King
you're muted
he muted he muted his Zoom
can you imagine Zoom there you go okay I
got a perfect example for you king among
us
no marketing one of the most iconic
games that was out at that time yep yeah
no it it is proven and it was all
because a couple big streamers on
Twitter golf yeah and they remember even
seeing these sort of resurgence when
streamers were playing it Summit one
yeah straight single-handedly
probably put the that money and like
look I'm not gonna sit there and say
that traditional marketing doesn't have
a place but when it comes to the gaming
industry that is a very unique style
type of Industry that it's hard to
promote that on a billboard right the
only thing I would push back on
Microsoft is I'm with all y'all but I
don't feel they do enough to promote
like Game Pass though like I feel like
people like we know it but it's like the
services Gamepad I feel like they should
do a little bit better there you know
but that's just me you know I just feel
like I mean you got game pass at
Kentucky Fried Chicken game passes well
I didn't know that game pass at
um Oreos cookies and you know Nabisco
and all of these places they they trying
to hit the market in certain places what
I would say is they have to do
Partnerships right yeah if they do
partners and they did the Partnerships
with LG and they did the Partnerships
with Samsung uh I think those
Partnerships need to be highlighted more
right okay uh put it on the box of the
television okay in this television you
have the Game Pass App that's on you
know put the stick on it's not too much
uh you have to spend a ton of money it's
just the way that you have these
Partnerships you have to leverage your
partnership in order to get the maximum
I agree so I want to read this comment
from uh
uh from 10 Clan I'm not gonna a q-tang
clan is that is that yeah
my 12 year old didn't know what star
food was until he got the controller and
headset when he found out it was made by
the people who made Skyrim he was height
that's the only reason I feel like they
could do more traditional marketing
because this this isn't No Ordinary
developer this is probably one of the
most prominent developers that's ever
been around they have probably the most
Game of the Year continues if not game
of the years you can Market this
traditionally I understand why they
don't but I do understand you know
people like kids food that wants to see
more traditional marketing from
Microsoft it's just I don't think that
they understand you know how much that
marketing has died out throughout the
years yeah no I agree I think it's a
changing of the god the the thing that I
will say though that I still want them
to not stop doing is like when Halo
infinite came out we had that Halo
infinite console remember how quickly we
was like boom so Starfield to me was
like yo that was that was one don't get
me wrong the headsets you got attic fire
the controller fire like it just needed
that you know Trifecta especially little
man little man would have been fired
with the ass you know what I'm saying
though
face they got space Oh I would have been
very disappointed if there was only a
series s especially oh I got you but
whatever whatever cause I don't care
what it is if it acts as whoever I just
what do you think if they if they hit
you with the we could only do one I feel
like that's not acceptable don't do it
at all if you're just gonna do one
because there's got all these people
that haven't asked all these people that
haven't asked these people that want
each and they're like we can only give
an S I'mma be pissed but they kind of
did but you got the people that don't
have an X got the majority of the people
they're having us are going to be mad
but they kind of did it with infinite
remember I don't remember seeing us too
serious I say have no um
[Music]
he had to stay in white
I think that's just one of those things
you know yeah I think that's one of
those things that maybe you just have to
make people mad like it's like it is
what it is you know you have the S
upgrade of the X if if you want this wow
yeah
and last thing is yeah it looks like um
area uh I guess a stalker uh shout out
to boxer but he said hellblade 2 will be
in the theater so hopefully maybe they
show some comment or something something
new with that would be dope towerborne
um new Microsoft Flight similar stuff
um Elder Scrolls online and then armor
core like we said party animals remember
the fun low yeah yeah a little that
cyberpunk
it's gonna end bad it's the as soon as
he said they're gonna have um hellblade
too there it's gonna end bad if they
show the same clip
yeah Hellboy 2 is going to be there yeah
it's gonna end back oh my God that
question
we got um we got quakecon coming up this
week yeah
yeah something well shout out to VGC
there's a leadership
video games Chronicles leak about what
maybe uh announced that quakecon so
maybe we get some more details on that
uh whatever it is
uh according to our friends over at
video games Chronicle
there is a quake 2 remastered
covering that story
but it was it had been rated in Korea
earlier in the year so uh the assumption
is that at quakecon they will be talking
about the next you know iteration of
quake and maybe maybe we've heard uh
Rumblings of maybe uh bringing it back
bringing it back in full force so maybe
maybe there's a little bit of talk about
that but yeah I love quick yeah the
streets were talking about that uh yeah
yeah so you're just gonna go with that I
don't know but uh we're gonna say oh
payday 3 and the last thing is I do want
to see uh Persona 5 tactica because I
think it's turn based uh Persona just
you know I want to see a little take on
it but now look I like it they gotta
have a big presence there PC game pass
the whole bit it's good to see them in
your where traditionally they all week
so that's all I got